the jurogan experience i do think
there's a limit to the amount of
technological progress
that we will make yeah like i don't
think it'll keep going forever or that
i guess what i'm saying is i i feel like
i encounter
a lot of people
that are
sort of techno-utopians like we'll be
able to figure out anything we can think
of now we will eventually make
it's possible though but i think there
will be a limit there'll be stuff we can
think of that we'll never be able to do
like what i don't know what i just think
that
if you
like if you assume that
humans are not the most intelligent
possible beings that could physically
exist compatible with the laws of
physics of the universe which i think is
true like we're not sure of course the
the most intelligent
and
like it would stand to reason that there
are things
it's possible to do there are things the
laws of physics don't rule out
that we simply aren't intelligent enough
to do that like we aren't intelligent
enough to ever
figure out i think that's assuming that
we're not going to merge with technology
in a symbiotic way that advances our
cognitive ability and i think that's
inevitable but what if what if merging
with technology is already something
we're unable to figure out because
we can't conceptually understand
consciousness
readily enough
um
well consciousness whether we understand
it or not we could still manipulate it
the thing about technology and the
symbiotic
sort of uh future of humans and
technology when you talk to e have you
ever talked to elon no talk to elon
about it he's developing neural ink and
neuralink is essentially going to be
some sort of an implant that they um
they they cut a hole in your [ __ ]
head and they put wires inside your
brain and change the way you interface
with information and and he was
explaining to me he goes you're going to
be able to talk without words
and when he says you're going to be able
to talk without words it's not like one
of my stoner buddies bro you're going to
be able to [ __ ] talk without words
i'm like man maybe something like that
but when he says it he's got a [ __ ]
plan and he's going to start with people
that have problems with their uh
with neurological issues
people that have
nerve damage people that have spinal
cord injuries they're going to replace
the ability to move and use some sort of
computer controlled technology that
replaces
what the the function of the spinal
column
then from there they're going to move to
human beings advancing their cognitive
function they're going to move to
changing the way they interface with i'm
skeptical they'll get there
why
so
last year i
i got a cough it wasn't covered
and were you sad
was i sad that i wasn't going yeah a
little bit yeah i was like damn
everybody is everybody hopes they just
have a [ __ ] cough yeah
and i went to the doctor it just wasn't
going away you know and i'm i'm a
podcaster i'm a rapper i'm a musician i
need my voice it wasn't going away you
still have a little cough now i do a
little bit is that the same cause no
it's not the same coconut this cough is
from omicron which i had like six weeks
ago really yeah but it went it had it
for four weeks lingered went away for
two weeks
so it's a it's a me thing it's it's not
covered it's me all right
my costs tend to linger a little bit for
a long time anyway
i went to the doctor
and the doctor was very kind he like did
an x-ray of my chest for free
and just just just kind of being nice i
was like listen i'm a pi i really need
to [ __ ] get rid of this cough it's
been a month i have no idea what to do
and um he said you know it's probably
just mild bronchitis after you saw the
x-ray do you want me to prescribe you
anything and i was like what do you why
are you asking you're the doctor don't
that's why i'm coming here is because
you're supposed to say that things tell
me the things and he's like
i don't know man um
he can give you some stuff he's probably
not gonna do anything but
and i was like yeah just just give me
everything he's like all right any
bacterial
steroids
this other thing so that took everything
did nothing
robitussin over-the-counter cough
medicine you know turns out the [ __ ]
does not work for everyone it did
nothing for me and then i looked up the
meta-analysis studies of robitussin
in meta-analysis versus a placebo has
almost no effect
did you know that really yes
there are meta-analysis compiling
studies of robitussin versus placebo
that find tiny effect sizes
well nyquil used to get you high as [ __ ]
did they change it i think they did
for sure right yeah that's what robo
trip and they had to stop that there was
like uh
coding in it i think dude
once i had nyquil once in the 90s i'll
never forget it yeah i was i was sick
and i took nyquil and i was laying in my
bed and i was as happy as i've ever been
in my life i was like i feel so loved i
just feel so like one with everything it
was just i was like oh my god i'm so
happy
yeah i was like this like ah
yeah and i remember thinking so this is
why people like niko i don't think
before that time and i was like in my
20s at the time i was like i don't think
i've ever really had nyquil
right like really had it and especially
not as an adult where i could like
recognize what's going on
i was like i'm so high yeah i mean
nyquil even now kind of feels good what
is it it used to be
right yeah that's what i was just
looking up dextromethorphan yeah right
what was nyquil in the 90s was it
codeine
it was [ __ ] strong though
i mean bring it back how come i can't
have it now
[ __ ]
anyway my point about bringing up the
cough story
was
there are certain problems
uh
like okay let me put it this way we have
intuitions about which are the hard
problems and which are the easy problems
right
and sometimes those intuitions are just
way off so it turns out putting a man on
the moon was easier than curing the
common cough reliably
i wouldn't guess that if i were like a
human in like
1890 i would have been like they'll
probably cure the cough
before they put a guy safely
in space
it turns out we haven't done that
and
my guess
is that the neuralink stuff
is going to be more like a common cough
type of problem where it's like
we think we're making progress but it
turns out to be so much more difficult
than we can even
realize that
you know it's like 500 years from now
and we still haven't gotten it
that's possible
it's also possible that they do it and
then they keep expanding on it and
they keep innovating and then the
competition starts kicking in and other
people start developing
new sorts of human brain interfaces and
it gets extremely valuable to the point
where you cannot compete without it and
it becomes a thing where everybody has
just like everybody has a cell phone now
you know if they can figure out a way to
get people to interface with technology
where you can literally share data and
information back and forth without
talking that's an invaluable skill and
or
ability
whether or not that actually is
implemented i don't know but elon has a
[ __ ] plan
and that's the smartest guy i've ever
talked to and he talks about definitely
not he's explaining how it's going to
work he's not like it's not pie in the
sky [ __ ]
no but i think
so this is this goes back to my point
about intelligence is often not why
people get things wrong it's not that
they're not intelligent
it's that sometimes when you're in an
industry
and you have that hammer everything
looks like a nail
so it's like
the people in tech
are going to be the ones to overestimate
what tech can do precisely because
they're in tech
yeah just like the surgeon the surgeon
is gonna think you can solve everything
with surgery because he's a [ __ ]
surgeon right right
and so it's not that they're
unintelligent it's that
um sometimes you know people tend to
overestimate
the importance of their industry or the
ability of their industry to solve
everything it's a systematic bias i
think people have across the board
so often people with it on the inside
are some sometimes the worst judges of
the limits of
their own enterprise
that does make sense however
technological innovation seems to be one
of the main consistent factors in human
civilization
and the explosion of technological
innovation that's taken place over the
last 30 years
and particularly over the last you know
whatever it has been since the internet
was really fully implemented into
everyone's household it's been
mind-boggling
and i don't see it slowing down
and i think that the next logical step
is to go from something you carry around
to something that's a part of your body
and i think they'll do it first for
people with injuries
and then once they
and they've already have that they
already have things where they allow
people to move a mouse around with their
brain
they already have things where people
with previously paralyzed hands can now
use them
they have those things
the logical
sort of
technological innovation if you
extrapolate from where we are now to
where we're going whether it takes 10
years or 50 years or 100 years i think
the symbiotic connection between humans
and technology is probably the only way
we beat out artificial intelligence
i think the big fear is that someone
creates artificial intelligence and that
thing becomes sentient and then that
thing creates better artificial
intelligence far superior to ours and
does it very quickly they they find all
the flaws that we have and they come up
with a new version of us and that we're
not going to be able to compete and that
is this sort of silicon-based life form
will be far more advanced than us but
without emotions without all the
biological problems that we have without
the desire for breed and ego and all it
won't be programmed with any of those
problems so we'll just seek advancement
and technological innovation for
whatever [ __ ] reason
i don't know why i mean maybe it would
have no motivation to do anything it
would just stop dead in its tracks
because it would realize that the
existence is futile
but
i think the way to stop that is we
become symbiotic and we we integrate
with technology and that technology
advances our capability and as elon says
it advances our bandwidth for accessing
information
yeah i mean i can't i mean i can't
justify this with much more than a gut
feeling but
gut feelings are great yeah i mean gut
feelings come from somewhere they come
from
hopefully from years of learning about
the world and guessing and being wrong
and being right it's where intuitions
come from but my intuition tells me that
this is going to be one of those
problems that we
underestimate
the difficulty of by orders of magnitude
it's like how close are we to
understanding the brain
anywhere close enough
how many neurons are there in the brain
again it's a good question
it's like how many so many more than you
think billions probably trillions i
believe yeah really i think it's
trillions is it trillions i think it is
how close are we to
truly yes
truly to like
okay oh god i'm gonna say three trillion
no i'm gonna say
2 trillion 999
86 billion oh okay a close to average
average between 80 cents oh it's not
that many
that's earth when we have optimal uh
population density
how close are we to understanding the
brain
it's 86 billion neurons not totally
close that's the question that's an
understatement of the century we're not
even like
yeah we're not we're like dipping our
toe in
to
like the pacific ocean it's like the
pacific ocean and we like kind of are
starting to understand like
maybe what water is
yeah i don't know it's like we're at the
beginning
and and i guess my point is
uh an understanding complete enough to
integrate with technology
it's not at all obvious to me that we
will ever get there
you know like we could make progress
forever but it can be like asymptotic
progress like there's there's an there's
an asymptote here
and it's what's that word it's like uh
well you know like in math like how a
graph can like approach the limit of a
thing without ever touching it and get
infinitely closer to a line without ever
touching it and go on forever
like this so
it's like if you imagine we make
asymptotic progress there's this line
that because of our intelligence
you know in our our the fundamental fact
that we're not wired by evolution to
understand the world perfectly we're
wired to evolve and reproduce basically
on the african savannah right
and just like every other animal in the
world
there's a limit to the things we are
able to understand
right um
that limit for humans is way further
than for any other animal
but fundamentally it's not infinite and
um
again it would stand to reason there are
problems in the world
that we may not we may not even be able
to understand the problems much less the
solutions i would say probably
consciousness so far is looking like one
but the point is
it's possible we could keep making
progress technologically forever but
it's asymptotic progress in the sense
that there's a line here that we keep
approaching and it keeps looking like
we're making progress because we are
but
you know there's a line we're never
gonna hit so it can be true at the same
time that we keep making progress
forever and that there is a limit to
that progress that's asymptotic and
certain things are
um
be just beyond that line and my my
intuition tells me that merging with
understanding the brain and
understanding you know silicon
well enough to merge them is probably
beyond that line